this video is brought to you by
morningbrook
hi welcome to another episode of cold
fusion
last time in our intel mini series we
looked at how the company invented the
cpu microprocessor in 1971
and by the 2010s were at the top of
their game they became the go-to
processor company in every consumer
desktop product and an unstoppable force
or so it seemed in today's episode
we'll see how intel's size became a
hindrance and how
behind the scenes they were trying to
kill competition with bribes and
monopolistic tactics
let's take a look
despite its brilliant start and massive
size
in recent years intel has seen
bureaucracy and brain drain
vital executives have left and
accountants and business majors became
major decision makers
but i can tell you in silicon valley i
came here in 1970 until was exactly two
years old
uh the very first year working at
stanford and my ph.d in
integrated electronics i met neuse and
moore and they began a recruiting
process
i wanted to know what i was going to
work on that was going to change the
world
and now we've got a ceo there talking
about which parts he's going to chop
off and sell and we've got you know the
buzzards flying around
talking about you know strategic options
and stuff like that
not okay something's got to change well
what needs to change
well they need a new ceo the ceo needs
to be technical if you look at advanced
micro devices for example
uh they've caught up tremendously on on
intel
in intel's area and their ceo is a phd
and also a good ceo
so you've got to get somebody
disrespected by the technical community
for sure
according to the employer rating agency
glassdoor only 84
of the firm's workers recommend the
company and 85
of them recommend the ceo meanwhile at
amd and nvidia
99 of employees recommend their ceos
intel insiders have noted the extensive
use of cheap foreign contractors
whose working visas are used to hold
them to ransom
these foreign workers are only assigned
specific tasks
and can't stray from it a far cry from
the free experimentation that robert
noyce encouraged back in episode 1.
to make things worse intel spends 13
billion dollars in research
and development meanwhile nvidia spends
3 billion
and amd under the leadership of dr lisa
spends just 1.8 billion
and for all of that spending that intel
does they don't have much to show for
themselves in fact
as you'll later see the company has been
embroiled in scandals and
anti-competitive behaviour
events that have been largely missed by
the public eye
we'll get to the juicy details of
intel's dirty tactics in the second half
of this episode
but before we get to all of that let's
take a look at how intel lost the mobile
market
as we saw in a cold fusion episode about
apple's arm-based
m1 chip intel missed the boat on the
mobile revolution
the company had the opportunity to make
chips for apple's upcoming iphone
but then ceo paul ottalini just didn't
see it as a profitable venture
in the end intel passed on the
opportunity leaving the door wide open
for arm-based designs
but this wasn't the full story contrary
to popular belief
intel wasn't caught completely off guard
by the rise of smartphones and mobile
devices
they saw arm-based chips coming and
decided to get in on the action
as far back as 2002 they used arm-based
designs in what they called the intel x
scale processor series
but due to poor sales and bad management
the project was abandoned and sold off
in 2006
before any real success but they kept
trying and by 2014
intel was losing a billion dollars per
quarter in failed mobile endeavours
[Music]
next the firm would throw four billion
dollars per
year at tablet manufacturers and this
was to encourage them to use intel cpus
it kind of worked but as soon as intel
stopped paying
the tablet manufacturers would switch
back to armbase chips
by 2016 intel just gave up on the mobile
market with over 10 billion dollars
being lost
in trying
out of all the semiconductor giants
intel is in a unique position
they're the only ones that own and
operate chip manufacturing plants
this vertical integration means that
intel employees not only have to design
the chips but
also have to figure out how to
manufacture them all the way down to the
transistors at the nanometer level
admittedly it's not an easy job the
thing is
none of intel's competitors do this not
amd
or nvidia instead they use companies
such as taiwan semiconductor
manufacturing company
known as tsmc global foundries or
samsung to produce their chips
for the longest time for intel making
their own ships in-house was seen as an
advantage
but recently they just haven't been able
to keep up
to understand exactly what intel is
struggling with we have to talk a little
bit about how cpu chips are made
[Music]
modern cpus are made using
photolithography where an image of a cpu
is etched onto a piece of silicon
the exact method of how this is done is
usually referred to as the process
node and is measured by how small a
manufacturer can make the transistors
as a rule of thumb the smaller the
transistors the better
as transistors get tinier and more
tightly packed electrons don't have to
physically travel as far when moving
between them
this saves both calculating time and
energy
smaller transistors also mean that
calculations can be done without getting
too hot
and that's usually a limiting factor in
cpu performance
so for example with 7 nanometer
transistors compared to 14 nanometers
you can get 25 more performance under
the same power
it almost seems like magic but that's
how it works there's a bit more to the
story in terms of how you classify node
sizes
but overall that's the basic concept
[Music]
so the problems for intel all started on
september 5th
2014. that's the day that intel
introduced their fifth generation core
chips
these were supposed to be monumental the
company's first processors
using a 14 nanometer manufacturing
process intel was at the cutting edge
while amd remained stuck on the 28
nanometer process
intel wasn't going to sit still their
original plans had road maps for 10
nanometers to launch in 2016
with even more advanced seven nanometer
chips launching in 2018
but from here things slowly went wrong
to reach the 10 nanometer stage intel
tried to use exotic technology to
aggressively increase their chip density
but it backfired
and majorly the technical issues in
solving this
saw seven years of delays and to this
day
intel's current 10th gen core desktop
processors remain on a heavily optimized
but still
14 nanometer process and all of these
delays
opened the door for its competitors
[Music]
on the other side of the fence for amd
after some setbacks and with the help of
tsmc
amd struck back big time with their new
horizon chair processors in 2017
it featured up to 16 cores on a 14
nanometer process
it was a monster that slaughtered intel
in multi-threaded tasks
and overall value but it still lagged
behind in gaming and single thread
performance
but in 2018 the second generation ryzen
chip from amd
improved both performance and price
in 2019 with intel still stuck on 14
nanometers
amd took the technological lead with its
3rd gen ryzen cpus
now being built on an advanced 7
nanometer process
but there's a few intricacies going on
behind the scenes intel
was still hanging in there they had been
fine-tuning the performance of their 14
nanometer processors and had greatly
enhanced
integrated graphics but many
technological commentators
saw all of this as a technical failing
on intel's behalf
as it stands intel's unreleased and
upcoming 11th gen
seems like it's about four percent
faster than amd and gaming
despite still being 14 nanometer however
in multi-threaded workloads like content
creation amd
is offering better value with more cores
and threads for the money
and it could just be a matter of time
before intel was overtaken
even in gaming and this isn't going over
silently
consumers have been noticing intel slips
intel not only pushed back
10 nanometer chips to the end of 2021 in
freaking 2021
they also moved seven nanometer
production to a much later date 2022
or beyond you know that even after
slashing your prices
as much as 50 on your rehashed hardware
you've still got nothing and you'll
grasp at
any desperate strategy to avoid any
direct comparisons
against your competitor's product with
this plan
to launch first by a matter of hours
why so that the launch day reviews which
tend to get referenced by buyers over
the entire product lifecycle
couldn't contain direct comparisons to
something you were afraid
was going to be better you are a weasel
and you are a chicken
you seek to misrepresent the strength of
your products to consumers
weasel and you seek to duck away from a
fight
rather than take the criticism that you
know you deserve chicken
uh nothing special another ryzen 1600
i'm gonna just i'm gonna have to do like
the intel
edition just to see if anyone's still
running intel systems these days oh my
god they're all rising
intel's dead now aren't they wow if this
doesn't just tell you
how much momentum amd has
amd's success is all thanks to the chip
manufacturing company
tsmc who ramped up their seven nanometer
process extremely fast
this is something that intel simply
couldn't compete with in-house
and tsmc isn't sitting still they're
planning to move to five nanometers this
year
if this allows amd to get to five
nanometers in their desktop chips
before intel hits 10 nanometers intel
may be in trouble
remember intel was supposed to have 10
nanometers back in 2015.
and to make things worse the upcoming
4th gen ryzen chips from amd
are using a 5 nanometer process and is
said to be 40
faster in overall performance you've had
big problems with 10 nanometer
now with seven who and what at
intel is responsible for this string of
problems
well i mean ultimately um i'm i'm
responsible
before we continue let's take a look at
some intel news brought to you by
today's sponsor morningbrew
despite all their problems intel brought
in record sales due to the pandemic
more people working from home meant more
people buying laptops with intel chips
in them
the interesting thing about this was
that intel was forced to reveal their
sales numbers early
after they had been hacked intel's
problems are getting so severe
that investors such as third point are
calling for intel to split up its design
and manufacturing operations
if you want more stories like this one
and are interested in science technology
and business
morning brew is a great way to catch up
on all the latest news
if you're short on time it pulls
together quality news sources
all in one place without you having to
put in the effort
it's delivered straight to your email
inbox each weekday and saturday
and it's free it takes just 5 seconds to
sign up
so click the link in the description
below to get started
amd has gained market share for 10
straight quarters
breaking 20 desktop market share for the
first time since 2013.
amd's ryzen desktop cpus has remained on
top of amazon's cpu bestseller list
for years now according to ceo lisa
in 2020 ryzen cpus were topping the
retailer best seller list
and have more than 50 share of premium
processor sales at many top global
retailers
there's no denying that amd is at their
best
and in saying this amd has been a thorn
in the side of intel for the better part
of four decades
a thorn that intel has been trying to
remove
as you saw in the last episode of this
series amd began life
licensing intel's designs as a secondary
source supplier
if you remember intel had to do this as
a chip manufacturer because building
chips back then
was seen as unreliable and companies
wanted the confidence that they could
receive a chip
if there was an issue with one supplier
the bickering between the two companies
began in the early 1980s
even though intel had signed a
partnership with amd they decided to
break the agreement internally by
refusing to exchange the designs in
intellectual property with amd
this would result in a long legal
dispute that went to the california
supreme court
the court found that intel violated
amd's rights
intel was also accused of obstruction of
justice
during the trial they repeatedly stalled
and gave useless information
by this stage intel had taken the lead
by hampering amd's progress
in 1996 amd was forced to make their own
processes from the ground up
called the athlon series these new amd
cpus
ended up being faster than intel's
pentium 3 and much faster than intel's
pentium 4.
over the coming years intel became
nervous and needed to protect their
product sales
at all costs
in the early 2000s intel would offer
money to japanese companies such as nec
fujitsu toshiba sony and hitachi
as well as german retailers this bribe
money was so that these companies would
not use
amd parts and sell intel-based laptops
and cpus instead
amd sued intel for antitrust intel's
response
it was amd's fault that they were
failures in the marketplace
in 2004 the offices of intel's japanese
subsidiary was raided during an
investigation
intel was ruled to have violated
anti-trust laws in 2005.
the next year the intel offices in korea
were raided for the same reason
intel had also violated antitrust laws
there too
next intel german officers would be
raided in 2008
same reason starting to see a pattern
intel's many international bribes to
companies to shut out amd processors
from the market would be uncovered
and they would be fined over a billion
dollars for it
it got worse though in 2009 even
companies like dell
hp nec and lenovo were all involved in
intel's bribes
in the legal filings it was stated that
consumers even asked for cheaper and
better performing amd
chips but dell refused dell wanted to
keep receiving money from intel which
was making up
104 percent of their quarterly income at
one stage
another anti-trust lawsuit was filed by
the district of new york in 2009
it revealed six billion dollars in
quarterly payments
from intel to dell from 2001 to 2006.
in 2010 intel was caught faking
benchmarks by using custom code that
could detect which cpu the benchmark was
running on
benchmarks are seen by consumers as an
easy way to determine which products
have better performance
if this particular benchmark saw that it
was running on an intel cpu
it would run a highly optimized code if
it saw something else
it would run the slowest version of the
code it could find this mislead
consumers and manufacturers alike
and intel were prosecuted by the ftc
over this
and it just kept going in 2018 with the
launch of the amd
ryzen threadripper a monster 32 core cpu
intel had to think of something so their
marketing team went into overdrive
intel would retaliate against amd by
demonstrating the power of their 5
gigahertz 28 core processor
it looked awesome in benchmarks but
there was only one issue
intel would later claim that they
somehow forgot to mention
that this demo chip was overclocked and
required a 1
700 watt industrial freezer to keep it
from overheating
as demonstrated the performance that
intel was showing off didn't exist in
any chip they currently had
in 2019 with the launch of their core i9
9900k
the benchmark showed a massive
performance advantage over amd
the only problem some of these
benchmarks were sponsored by intel
and as it turned out through software
the intel sponsored benchmarks disabled
the number of cores of amd
chips by half intel would go on to
fabricate many benchmarks throughout the
year and you can check out the channel
adored tv if you want a detailed
overview of intel's bad practices
to me it's really amazing that intel has
been operating like this for decades
but most people just aren't aware they
struggled with innovation
so they settled for dirty tactics there
was a time at intel where we
the people used to joke that they kept
advanced micro alive in order to make it
so the justice department didn't force
them to break up
they literally kept it alive well they
don't keep it alive anymore
they have caught and passed intel
when it comes to those key growth areas
in 2018 and 2019 intel struggled with
hardware security vulnerabilities
one of which affected all of intel's
cpus since 1995
and is impossible to completely fix
during the ordeal
the company offered to pay security
researchers 80 000
as a reward if they could downplay the
severity of the vulnerabilities
in one case intel knew about a backdoor
vulnerability that affected all of their
cpus
and didn't fix it for 10 years until a
hacker leaked some information on it
when microsoft a name synonymous with
intel decides to build their own chips
you know something is wrong
after apple shocked the industry with
the m1 chip microsoft announced that
they would be using arm technology to
build their own chips
they already use arm-based snapdragon
chips and some of their surface
line computers but these can't hold a
candle to the m1
so microsoft is getting serious and
building something by themselves
if this chip is competitive and low
power this would be yet another blow to
intel
and on another point mac os is about 10
of the total pc market
so losing this plus ever more market
share to amd
is definitely going to hurt intel
on the topic of intel struggling with
their manufacturing process to try and
get to 10 nanometers
in july of 2020 then ceo bob swann
stated that if more things go wrong for
intel
they may use a third party like samsung
or tsmc
swann would be fired in early 2021 but
intel would still go through with the
plan
stating that for their seven nanometer
process intel would outsource
manufacturing of these chips for
products starting in 2023
and this is actually a bright spot for
intel a key point in this entire story
this decision may actually be the best
thing for the company in many years
swallowing their pride and admitting
that they just couldn't hold their
position in chip manufacturing
is definitely a turning point for intel
the semiconductor industry is inherently
risky companies must bank on the fact
that these technologies have to work
they have to be well planned to beat out
the competition but as
intel found out when things go wrong
they can go very wrong
intel tried to both manufacture and
design their own chips but they couldn't
keep up with global foundries in the us
or the korean or taiwanese companies but
don't get me wrong
financially intel is doing very well
their desktop market is still solid
and they have a huge legacy and they're
making a bunch of money hand over fist
intel aren't going away tomorrow but
consumers are starting to be unsatisfied
and the recent turn of events in the
past three years was a wake-up call
for intel firing ceos from accounting
backgrounds like bob swan
and many previous ceos and finally
putting an engineer in charge
as well as swallowing their pride when
it comes to manufacturing could see a
major turnaround
and it must be said in the grand scheme
of things all of this
is not easy to do in any cpu there's
billions of transistors nanometers in
size
and every single one of them has to be
perfect it's incredible that we can
achieve such amazing feats of
engineering in the first place
the dna of intel has clearly changed
since their inception
but that's expected after 50 years so
what do you think is next for the
company
do you think they'll be back to the
darlings of the semiconductor industry
in a few
years or will they be the next ibm feel
free to discuss below
so i want to thank you for watching the
whole way through this episode i really
appreciate it
if you did enjoy it feel free to
subscribe to cold fusion i also recently
went on the tech society podcast if
you're interested
so i'll leave a link below to that as
well
my name is dagogo and you've been
watching cold fusion and i'll catch you
again soon for the next episode
cheers guys have a good one
[Applause]
it's me thinking
[Music]
right